we told you earlier that president-elect
joe biden plans to announce the first
appointments to his cabinet tomorrow
joining us now is someone
who knows the former vice president and
has worked on presidential transitions
that's bill daley a former white house
chief of staff for president barack
obama
he's now vice chairman of public affairs
at wells fargo only on cbs this morning
he's announcing the bank's new campaign
to help americans in need during the
pandemic mr daley good morning to you
i want to get to the wells fargo program
because hunger is a very big issue in
the country right now and the bank's
gift is an important one
but first i want to talk about tony
blinken he
is going to be the secretary of state
we're reporting
he's someone you you've worked with in
the obama administration and also the
clinton administration
what can you tell us about him
tony is a very solid fellow who's very
close to the
to the president-elect biden and that's
a enormous advantage for our secretary
of state
they've worked together for years he's
smart he knows the world
he is not going to be a secretary of
state or somebody speculated about
running for
senate from some state he's going to
focus on doing the job which is
vitally important to the future of our
country so i think there's no one i can
think of better for
president-elect biden to pick than tony
blanken biden called him a superstar
back in 2013. let's talk about treasury
secretary for
a moment janet yellen has been suggested
as a possible pick elizabeth warren has
also
been suggested as a possible pick her
rise to prominence included some sharp
questioning of the former wells ceo
over the fake account scandal is there
somebody that wells uh
in your office uh would like to see in
the position of treasury secretary
no i think that would be presumptuous of
us obviously the president-elect will
pick who he thinks
is talented one speculation about
senator warren obviously she's very
feels very strongly about financial
issues and she's been very vocal on them
one of the things politically it's
difficult to appoint a democratic
senator to a cabinet spot
if there's a republican governor who
would replace that senator with a
republican
that then shrinks the number of
democrats in the senate and that's a
hard political thing to do
but but whoever the president-elect
picks
i'm sure they're going to be dedicated
to keeping our economy strong
as we come out of this pandemic and
getting us back to a point where you
have much lower unemployment
and less pain for people in america so
let's talk food let's talk hunger
thanksgiving is on thursday but tens of
millions of americans many of them
never thought they'd be in this position
are facing hunger
today what's wells fargo doing to
address that problem
well we're launching a plan a campaign
today many hearts
one community where we're really trying
to help people in need this pandemic and
lots of other things over the last years
has caused enormous pain we're
committing on our
we're fulfilling our commitment to
provide resources to feed
82 million provide 82 million meals to
americans
you've reported repeatedly on the
challenges that
many people have on getting meals and
for they and their children so
we're doing that the second part of our
campaign is to
provide uh frontline workers and
american military personnel
notes and thanks from our customers
employees
we're going to contribute up to a
million dollars to the red cross
so that people who are out there
fighting this and
fighting for us around the world know
that we appreciate their actions and
their sacrifices
third piece of our campaign to be honest
with you tony is to try to
help small businesses through these
holidays we're committing 50 million
dollars
over the next five weeks to help small
businesses and encouraging our customers
employees
to shop at small businesses because they
really are the backbone and they're
hurting
yeah hi uh kudos to wells fargo for
doing this but
if i'm listening i'm trying to figure
out how do i get it where do i go
if you go to wellsfargo.com uh you'll
get all the details
and and we'll we'll make it very easy
for people
to send notes uh to the frontline people
uh the the meals are going to be
provided by feeding america throughout
the country
and they'll be lo we'll be providing
locations and the
those local feeding america food banks
will be very uh visible that's how
that's so we're all trying to pull
together at a tough time
i thought you were going to give out
your cell and say call me i'll tell you
where to go but
we'll go to wellsfargo.com that's easy
to do well
they have been using some wells fargo
but not now
we'll talk later all right bill daley
thank you very much we appreciate it